health experts warn a coronavirus
variant first detected in britain will
become the dominant u.s strain in a
matter of weeks
making vaccinations even more urgent but
of the more than 42 million vaccines
administered so far less than 3 million
are known to have gone to residents of
long-term care facilities
jonathan vigliotti is in redwood city
california at one of the first
residential care centers
to have a major outbreak last spring
jonathan what did the staff tell you
about those vaccinations
and good morning to anthony they
describe this process as
incredibly frustrating listen we all
know people who have waited in line for
a vaccine for hours
gordon manor waited in line for months
they were told they were the priority
especially after
13 of their residents were killed by
kovid 19 last year
instead they faced red tape
alisa maliari 2 is the executive
director at gordon manor
responsible for the health and
well-being of 58 residents
after covid tore through her facility
last year she and her team enacted
strict covet protocols
they went about seven months without a
single case
then two residents tested positive in
november
we thought we were following all the
precautions you know we had been doing
this for months
so to be clear you're saying that since
last spring you've only had two
residents test positive
right that's incredible fear and the
threat
of coronavirus coming back in is
definitely a motivator
gordon manner enrolled in the federal
government's vaccine program for
long-term care facilities in
october but as that rollout stretched
into january
we had not received any communication
whatsoever from
anybody about when our turn was
it turns out that safeway called
and safeway was able to say hi we can
come and do a clinic at your facility
finally in late january all but one of
gordon manor's residents received their
first dose of the vaccine
before officials with the federal
vaccination program even reached out
among those vaccinated 91 year old
yolanda baldini
and 99 year old eunice dala costa
their sisters and roommates at gordon
manor on monday they got to visit
outside with yolanda's son
dennis baldini for the first time since
november
dennis how relieved are you to know that
your mother and your aunt
are now vaccinated oh they're repeated
although honestly i think they're safer
in here
than i am out there that's because
molieri 2
is taking no chances because i have
responsibility for gordon manor i need
to step up and figure it out i can't
wait
i can't wait for people to come save me
and molly re2 says her residents will
get their second dose
later this month she is relieved but
she's also worried for seniors
who are home alone without anyone in
their corner fighting for their shot at
a vaccine
gail yeah that's a big concern thank you
very much jonathan